bonjour C'est Marie-Hélène bienvenue
dans l'atelier des petits bricolages
aujourd'hui nous allons réaliser des
suspensions de Noël
pour réaliser la suspension il nous faut
du papier de couleur de Noël moi j'ai
choisi de couleur de Noël du vert et du
rouge
de la colle
de la ficelle couleur dorée
une perforeuse
un stylo argenté paillettes
des ciseaux
et enfin argenté pour écrire joyeux Noël
et quelques perles
alors donc on va dessiner une étoile
on va faire le contour
et on va découper les poils
voilà j'ai découpé les toiles
on va refaire une autre modèle avec la
fleur on refait le contour de la fleur
et on découpe la fleur
voilà la peur est terminée
voilà alors donc maintenant on a les
deux étoiles vertes et la rouge on va
les assembler avec du fil doré donc pour
cela nous allons perforer la première
étoile
on va prendre la perforeuse
voilà
la perforé qu'on va mettre le fil doré
donc on va
couper un petit morceau de fil
comme ça
on va mettre une petite perle pour
décorer
je vais prendre le blanc
voilà pour la première étape
on repère fort à nouveau là
on va rajouter l'étoile rouge donc on va
perforer aussi
on va bien centrer
donc là on va rajouter aussi
le fil
alors voilà on a terminé de rassembler
nos trois nos trois petites étoiles donc
on va maintenant les décorer
voilà donc on va écrire joyeux Noël avec
un petit feutre argenté
voilà donc joyeux Noël
joyeux Noël
puis on retourne
on va écrire derrière OK
joyeux
Noël
alors on va terminer notre guirlande
avec une petite touche finale de
brillant donc on va faire des petits
points
et voilà votre guirlande de Noël est
terminée et vous pouvez faire aussi avec
des fleurs
et mis soit aux autres et bon Noël et à
la prochaine émission au revoir